today that is starting after prag and
chis now and actually it is the third
time that at the core of our discussion
is our support for
Ukraine and this symbolizes also the
strong support that the European
political Community has for
Ukraine um I very much welcome that
president zinski is going to join us
here um on Monday the 27 ministers for
Foreign Affairs and the hrvp were in
Kiev to support Ukraine so there's a
strong message to Putin from Dublin to
chis now that we do not tolerate
aggression against a sovereign state one
of the topics here will also be energy
and indeed we had a massive energy
crisis due to the blackmail uh of Russia
with fossil fuels we've mastered this
crisis the prices have gone down
drastically and most importantly our
storage are filled and we have created a
joint platform to buy um uh gas together
this is a big success and the success is
seen into uh is can be seen uh because
of the fact that not only the 27 member
states have joined this platform for
energy but also other members of the
European political Community like Norway
Ukraine mova or
Serbia we have been able to get rid of
the Russian dependency uh on fossil
fuels uh we have massively invested in
Renewables and indeed last year for the
very first time the European Union was
able to produce more electricity from
Renewables wind and Sun then from gas
and of course Armenia will play a role
today in the discussions too I will meet
the Prime Minister of Armenia um in a
bilateral here we strongly support
support Armenia um and uh support it in
its humanitarian needs we have already
allocated 5.2 million euros I will tell
the Prime Minister today that I'm happy
that we double this amount to 10.4
million euros and that we are providing
15 million euros of direct budget
support under the country's annual
program and we will discuss what else we
can do to support um our menia in this
difficult
situation and you talked about what you
can do for Armenia but was there any
action that the European Union will take
against aan for a military operation
that has triggered the Exodus of 100,000
ethnic we have immediately um end of
September issued a very strong statement
of condemnation of uh the military
operation of azaran in nag kabak and
called strongly on uh a resuming of
dialogue and a peaceful solution this is
what we are working on and important for
us is to support
Armenia
ukan so we have been um it was very
important that President Biden informed
us at the beginning of this week what
the support for Ukraine is concerned
from the side of the United States um
here in the European we're working on a
package of 50 billion EUR for Ukraine
for the years 24 to 27 this is very
important because Ukraine needs
predictability and reliability in the
direct budget support um as far as I
oversee the situation in the United
States I'm very confident um of support
for Ukraine from the United States uh
what the United States is working on is
the
timing
developments regarding Sal gas and
turkey
gas